so Mark Zuckerberg has launched his app
threads they call it the Twitter killer
and I signed up to check it out and it
is awful I'm not just trying to play
some stupid tribal games the the main
feed on threads is a bunch of random
people I don't follow so I sign up for
this new Twitter killer and I'm like all
right let's check this out and I go to
my home page and there's like some dude
named Roderick talking about how him and
Jay boys was going down to the the
quartz hall for a for a new drink and
I'm like
I I have no idea what this guy's talking
about I don't want to follow him and you
can't you have to block them and so
people are literally like well I guess
what you do is if you see a post you
don't like block the person so you never
see it again like the whole thing is
this I'm getting a bunch of weird Brands
and garbage I don't care about but
anyway
it sucks but we'll talk more about it
and where it's at because sure enough
there is room to improve and some people
are excited there's an alternative to
Twitter because some people are still
banned on Twitter